et si biologie et psychologie étaient
les deux faces d'un même miroir
ressemblent tous à un parent un ongle un
grand père donc on sait que nos gènes
influencent qu'ils en aient nos
comportements mais à l inverse
est ce que nos comportements pourraient
modifier l'expression de nos gènes alors
ces questions dit neda qui m'ont
toujours passionné parce qu'en fait je
me demandais à quel point est-ce que je
suis libre d'être qui j'ai envie ou bien
je suis un peu prisonnière de ses
question d'hérédité
alors à la question qui suis-je
nietzsche nous répond deviens ce que tu
es
en réalité c'est une invitation nous
dépasse et nous libérer et à exprimer ce
qui nous fait vibrer alors
personnellement ce qui me fait vibrer
c'est le vivant c'est l'être humain
c'est essayer de comprendre l'être
humain ce n'est pas toujours évident et
puis par exemple très jeune je me savais
toujours du mal à comprendre pourquoi
est-ce que deux individus qui vivent un
même événement vont l'interpréter chacun
d'une manière très personnelle
et l'on peut retenir du tout la même
chose un autre événement m'a
profondément inspiré et à orienter ma
vie très certainement car à 11 ans je
perdais ma quatrième cousine de la même
maladie génétique la mucoviscidose et je
lui glisse est un poème secret dans sa
veste dans lequel je le faisais une
promesse celle de consacrer ma vie mon
énergie pour comprendre la génétique
comprendre qu'est ce qui faisait la
santé et la maladie et surtout aider des
personnes en souffrance
alors c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai décidé
d'étudier la biologie à 11 ans j'ai fait
tout mon programme de vie
j'étais j'avais tout planifié jusqu'à 35
ans et est juste avant mon doctorat
comme je me suis posé la question est ce
que cette expérience finalement va
définir tout ce que je suis et ce que
j'aurais fait un autre choix
sans cet événement est finalement la
réponse à ma question c'est j'aurais
étudié le cerveau parce que c'est ça qui
m'intéresse comprendre comment
fonctionne j'ai donc fait un doctorat de
neurosciences ça a été des années
passionnantes j'ai appris y ait
forcément plein de choses je manipule
elles vivent en faisant pousser mes
petites cellules en culture
je jouais avec l'adn j'avais des oreca à
4 heures du matin à mettre ensemble les
différentes pièces du puzzle pour
comprendre comment ces cellules
fonctionne franchement c'était grisant
mais j'ai terminé cette expérience
épuisé et un peu désabusé j'avoue on
m'avait prévenu c'est la maladie est
classique des doctorants j'avais du mal
à croire mais voilà donc j'ai pris
quelques mois pour réfléchir à la suite
parce que finalement j'avais toujours
pas répondu à mes questions et j'avais
besoin d'élargir mes horizons
j'avais besoin de contacts humains et
par hasard ou par chance j'ai rencontré
une femme qui m'a proposé de travailler
dans un institut psychiatrique
alors là je découvrais tout un monde
complètement nouveau parce que moi qui
connaissait la maladie la souffrance
physique je découvrais la souffrance
psychique
je découvrais comment ces individus qui
avaient vécu des choses terribles qui
avait manqué d'amour qu'avait vécu des
amours toxiques de la part de leur
entourage
comment ces êtres développer finalement
à l'adolescence à l'âge adulte des
troubles du comportement et même des
troubles psychiatriques
je découvrais la puissance de
l'inconscient chez eux mais aussi chez
moi
et finalement un jour j'ai accepté de
faire une expérience d'hypnose de
régression sous hypnose rien à voir
vraiment avec l'hypnose de spectacle
l'hypnose thérapeutique l'idée c'est
vraiment de deux d'être dans un état de
conscience modifiée qui nous permet
justement d'aller explorer notre
inconscient j'étais un petit peu
sceptique je me disais bon ok on va voir
si si je découvre quelque chose que je
connais pas encore sur moi sur le coup
ça a été un petit peu comme un rêve dans
lequel je suis restée consciente tout le
long et j'ai pas eu l'impression qu'il
se soit passé grand chose
d'extraordinaire c'est plusieurs mois
après que je me suis rendu compte que
finalement ça a changé ma vie
avant ça j'étais quelqu'un de très
sociable bon je suis je suis toujours
sociable mais avance à dix ans j'avais
besoin de remplir mon emploi du temps
d'être toujours occupé
professionnellement et personnellement
je n'avais pas beaucoup de temps pour
moi et après ça je me suis surprise à au
contraire apprécié ces moments de face à
face avec moi-même à découvrir mon monde
intérieur et découvrir cette bête
étrange la solitude et ça m'a emmené
finalement très loin puisque je suis
parti en voyage tout seul quelques
années après donc j'ai pu réaliser un
autre de mes rêves mais très
certainement j'aurais pas réaliser ce
voyage seul j'aurais pas le courage de
faire si j'avais pas fait cette séance
donc je suis parti en inde le pays par
excellence de l'introspection de la
méditation
j'ai continué ce travail sur moi et au
fur et à mesure je rencontrais tout un
tas de gens et sans m'en rendre compte
en fait je les guide est à leur tour
dans ce voyage à l'intérieur d'eux-mêmes
pour découvrir leurs souffrances leurs
limitations essayer de les libérer aussi
et voilà les choses se sont enchaînées
très naturellement quand je suis rentré
en 2012 je me suis donc installé en tant
que thérapeute indépendante et j'ai
réalisé cet autre rêve d'aider les gens
qui sont
qui sont dans la souffrance alors tout
ça pour vous expliquer que toutes ces
expériences en effet m'ont changé et
aujourd'hui un domaine de la science
nous parle de comment l'environnement et
ce qu'on vit peu s'imprimer dans nos
cellules
ça s'appelle l'épigénétique
l'épigénétique c'est quoi ce sont des
modifications chimiques qui vont changer
l'expression des gènes sans qu'il y ait
de changement dont la séquence de l'adn
ces gens ces changements peuvent être
héritée et irritable donc de cellule en
cellule au cours des divisions est
réversible
un exemple tout simple vous avez des
cellules de peau des cellules dos des
cellules nerveuses toutes ces cellules
sont différentes
comment c'est possible à partir d'une
même cellule à partir d'une même
séquence et six séquences ne change pas
du début à la fin de votre vie et
pourtant ces cellules sont différentes
c'est ça ça repose justement sur des
marques épigénétiques donc ces petites
modifications chimiques qui vont donner
à chaque type de cellule un profil
différent
alors ça c'est au niveau cellulaire
maintenant au niveau des organismes
entier je vais vous donner un exemple
très simple c'est celui des abeilles les
abeilles qui au départ sont toutes les
mêmes
finalement il y en a une qui va être
nourri à la gelée royale elle va devenir
deux fois plus grosse que les autres
quasiment et elle va être capable de
pondre donc on voit que l'environnement
ce qu'on va manger en tout cas ce que la
bei va va manger va changer ses
caractéristiques et ses capacités en
sciences on étudie souvent la souris
alors chez la souris
on a pu voir que des comportements
différents pouvaient être mis en lien
avec des profils épigénétiques différent
des souris par exemple qui ont peur et
qui reste dans une cage à lui mais qu'on
compare avec des souris qui elles sont
exploratrice qui vont aller dans la rue
dans la cage même si elle est atteinte
et settat et bien on voit quand ce ces
deux types de souris leurs différences
de comportement peut être mis en lien
avec des différences de marqueurs
épigénétiques ce qu'on voit aussi c'est
que le stress peut influencer ses
marques épigénétiques et derrière
influencer le comportement par exemple
chez des souris chez les souris en
gestation si la femelle est en contact
avec un mal qui va être agressif savalas
stressé et ce stress va avoir un impact
plus tard chez les petits un stress dans
les tous premiers stades de vie des
petites souris va également avoir un
impact sur leur gestion du stress plus
tard et va même pouvoir induire chez eux
un comportement dépressif
ça peut être un stress comme la
séparation de leur mère de manière
répétée et non prévus donc il n'a pas
toujours la même chose donc voilà j'ai
chez la souris on voit également que ces
marques épigénétiques qui sont donc la
conséquence de ce que la souris va vivre
et qui sont en lien avec des
comportements on voit que ces marques
peuvent être transmises au cours des
générations
ça nous fait poser beaucoup de questions
chez l'être humain comment ça se passe
alors c'est plus compliqué d'étudier
l'être humain mais un groupe et je
prends cet exemple parce que c'est des
études qui ont été réalisées ici à
genève
c'est ce groupe a étudié des femmes qui
avaient vécu des violences sexuelles ou
physiques dans l'or dans leur enfance et
ce qu'ils ont découvert ce qu'il y avait
un des indigènes qui a impliqué
également dans la réponse au stress qui
montraient une augmentation de la
méthylation et de manière intéressante
en noir donc cessé les contrôles et en
blanc on voit que c'est des personnes
qui ont été abusés plusieurs fois et
entre les deux c'est tous les
intermédiaires
donc en fait il ya même une augmentation
du nombre de méthylation en fonction de
la sévérité du traumatisme et des abus
et ils ont même pu prouver que l'une des
filles par exemple d'une femme violée
avait les mêmes marques épigénétiques
que sa mère alors qu'elle même n'avait
jamais été violée et la doctoresse rien
giacobino nous parle de cicatrices
présente dans l'adn et de cette
possibilité donc d'avoir une
transmission au cours des générations
alors est ce qu'on serait le produit en
effet des traumatismes qu'on a vécu mais
également ceux de nos ancêtres
il faut bien comprendre que tout ça
c'est valable pour chacun d'entre nous
finalement puisque un traumatisme
c'est quoi c'est un événement qui va
créer un choc émotionnel et qu'on
n'arrive pas à digérer qu'on n'arrive
pas à accepter
et finalement on sait depuis des
décennies les psychologues et
psychanalystes nous parle des des effets
des traumatismes des expériences sur les
comportements aujourd'hui la biologie
rajoute un maillon celle des empreintes
épigénétiques et de ce qui se passe dans
nos cellules alors en effet ça nous
concerne tous mais on n'est pas toujours
conscients de nos réactions
émotionnelles
d'ailleurs j'ai envie de vous poser une
petite question pour vous où se passent
les émotions est ce que vous pouvez me
dire comme ça à me montrer pour vous ou
est-ce qu'elles se passent les émotions
chez vous ok ok je vois que certaines
personnes me montre la tête
alors c'est ce que j'ai répondu la
première fois qu'on m'a posé la question
donc neuroscientifique ça se passe où
les émotions le cerveau limbique
neurotransmetteur la tête mais en fait
oui ça se passe aussi dans les intestins
j'ai entendu et dans le corps on peut
sentir cette construction dans le coeur
quand on est angoissé l'avons pas de la
peur au ventre
donc les émotions ça se passe aussi dans
le corps mais on n'a souvent pas
vraiment l'habitude d'aller écouter et
d'être en contact avec ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de nous et la question c'est
comment est ce qu'on fait pour se
libérer ses émotions aujourd'hui il ya
plus en plus de techniques qui travaille
sur la résolution des traumatismes
très souvent ces techniques qu'ils
utilisent l'hypnose ou des régressions
en tout cas vont nous amener à revivre
le traumatisme qu'elle est conscient ou
en tout cas vivre pleinement l'émotion
la ressentir et le fait d'accepter et de
d'accueillir tout ce qui se passe en
nous permet à un moment donné comme de
métaboliser ses sensations physiques
aujourd'hui il ya même un institut de
recherche qui travaille sur les pics
states c'est à dire les états de
conscience hyper fonctionner les états
de conscience de pointe qui nous
les apporte des états très très
confortable comme par exemple la paix
intérieure où la joie et qui nous
apporterait ses états en permanence et
en fait dans ce modèle grandes marques
fait which nous parle de comment la
conscience et les traumatismes pourrait
se comprendre un niveau biologique et
nous dit qu'on aurait tous accès à ces
états de conscience hyper fonctionnel
c'est simplement nos traumatismes et
ceux de nos ancêtres qui nous empêche de
les vivre
donc ma question aujourd'hui c'est quand
on effectue ce travail quand on se
libère de nos émotions
est ce que on efface ses cicatrices qui
sont dans les gènes
est-ce qu'on réveille quelque part ces
marqueurs épigénétiques qui vont qui
vont ceux qui vont arriver quand on vit
des traumatismes et je pense vraiment
que ça c'est là c'est le défi de la
biologie et de la psychologie du 21e
siècle et en tous cas c'est le défi que
je me lance pour les prochaines années
donc aujourd'hui mon message est ce que
j'ai envie de vous dire pour reprendre
la phrase de la phrase de nietzsche
c'est de vous inviter à devenir ce que
vous êtes à exprimer la plus belle
partie de vous parce que ça peut
vraiment changer des choses au niveau
des relations avec vos proches et
et toute la façon dont vous allez vivre
tous les jours
j'observe tous les jours des gens qui
changent de comportement pour vous
donner un petit exemple des personnes
qui ont des angoisses par exemple sans
savoir pourquoi le matin et se réveille
il ya une angoisse qui est là et en
quelques séances la personne va
totalement se libérer et cette
impression de jeu thoracique serré et
plus là où d'autres personnes et ça peut
être face aux partenaires face à un
enfant qui fait des remarques et à
chaque fois la personne va se sentir
soit agresser soit dévalorisé et pareil
en quelques séances
la réaction n'est plus la même le
sentiment en face n'est plus le même et
de manière incroyable ça change
la réaction de la fameuse personne en
face elle vient plus appuyé sur le
bouton qui était à la base douloureuse
donc voilà j'ai envie de vous inviter à
devenir qui vous êtes et la recette est
simple
alors c'était simple mais après le
travail un petit peu fastidieux c'est
d'abord de prendre conscience de qui
vous êtes
quels sont vos traumatisme quels sont
vos blocages vos peurs est ce que vous
avez envie d'être aussi ensuite c'est de
décider décidé de changer quelque chose
et parfois ces deux étapes quand on les
a faites et ben c'est pas je sais pas
suffisant parce qu'il faut trouver les
outils qui nous permettent de nous
libérer
hélas une fois de plus c'est pas je vous
demande pas de me croire moi là la
première je ne croyais pas à tout ça
mais par contre d'essayer et pour chacun
de vous les outils seront certainement
différent chacun doit trouver un petit
peu son chemin pour pouvoir se libérer
alors voilà je terminerai sur cette
phrase de carl gustav jung qui nous dit
que tout ce qui n'est pas mise en
confiance revient sous forme de destin
et je crois vraiment que le pouvoir est
en nous finalement et on en à ce devoir
de faire ce travail
pas uniquement pour nous mais c'est
également un acte de responsabilité pour
les générations futures
[Applaudissements]